hola que tal
excellent
qui j'imite
ba docteur nozman bien sur
on l'a reconnu
les amis aujourd'hui on est sur choixdemerde.fr
un site français on est content
parce que la France est un beau pays, où les baguettes sont bonnes
voila c'était ma repartie.
On a déjà fait des trucs similaires, en gros c'est un site où à chaque fois on va avoir le choix entre 2 trucs
nanana ou nanana
Et il faudra choisir euh la réponse qui nous correspond
Et on aura bien sûr le pourcentage de gens qui ont choisi la réponse
euh que tu as toi-même choisi
voir si tu penses comme tout le monde si t'es pas original ou si t'es différent des autres
ok la première
"Pouvoir être invisible mais devoir faire du bruit pour le rester"
c'est très très nul
ou alors "Voyager dans le temps mais tu dois rester sur un tricycle"
c'est...
très clairement voyager dans le temps tu pimp ton tricycle tu mets un petit moteur électrique
tsais tu regardes une vidéo de Nozman, t'apprends comment faire bim bim c'est bon t'es bien
Excellent, ça se voit que jregardes les vidéos de Nozman ou pas *rire*
allez hop le tricycle, bah oui, et bah voila 69% des gens ont pris le tricycle, c'était évident !
En plus sur ce modèle, tu possèdes un petit panier à l'avant qui permet de mettre par exemple ton casque
oui, pour un tricycle il faut un casque sur la tête
question suivante
un tatouage tribal ou un tatouage chinois ? *rire*
ah tous les mecs qui ont des tatouages tribal sont vexés de ouf
franchement un tatouage chinois plus que tribal
Oh! QUOIIII?! Mais mec pourquoi le tatouage tribal mon gars c'est euh c'est...nan je vais rien dire euh c'est bon
tatouage tribal nan c'est bien, c'est bien, il est beau
Nan mais c'est les goûts et les couleurs, mais je trouve ça tellement cheum le tribal quoi
Ya tellement mieux dans l'art abstrait quoi, ya beaucoup mieux que ça quoi enfin bref c'est mon avis !
C'est mon avis! Je respecte le votre même si il est nul, je le respecte.
"Poils de nez" ou "Poils d'oreilles" ?
Nan mais l'abus quoi...
Mec, dans les deux cas, c'est dégoutant, c'est répugnant : "Poils de nez" ou "Poils d'oreilles" ?
C'est une question existentielle que voilà
Nan franchement poils aux oreilles, poils aux oreilles
OOH!
Les gens préfèrent avoir des gros poils de nez!
Oh merde ! Ah le con!
"Tuer quelqu'un ou "Être ignoré de tous" ?
Avoir une vie de merde quoi en vrai
Bah tuer quelqu'un non on va éviter hein, on va préféré être ignoré de tous voilà.
Putain 789 personnes sont prêtes à tuer quelqu'un pour ne pas être ignoré de tous
Hallucinant
"Faire ses besoins dans une litière", "Faire ses besoins devant quelqu'un"
Devant Poutine par exemple
Euhm... Faire ses besoins devant quelqu'un c'est quand-même le truc le plus gênant du monde.
T'es seul tu t'en bats les couilles, faire caca dans un pot ou dans des toilettes ou dans une litière c'est la même
Donc dans une litière. Quoi 39% des gens préfèrent faire ça dans des toilettes mais devant quelqu'un.
Et l'intimité elle est où quoi mec, incroyable.
"Cyril Hanouna" ou "Une lamproie"
Ba mec
Touche pas à ma lamproie mon gars
Des "miettes dans le lit" ou une "étiquette qui gratte"
AAAAAH
Elle commence à me venère cette putain d'étiquette là !
Après ya des marques qui ont fait l'étiquette que tu peux  arracher à la main tu sais
Genre ya des pointillés tu peux l'arracher
Et du coup quand tu l'a retire elle te gratte encore plus, puisque c'est moins doux le bout.
Franchement les miettes dans le lit mec, à 3h du mat' t'as une grosse prise de conscience tu te lèves, tu prends ton petit dyson comme ça
*aspire*
On en parle plus, nan mais c'est vrai!
Ah 53% des gens préfèrent avoir le cul qui gratte quoi c'est hallucinant
"Ressembler à Ribery", "Ressembler aux frères Bogdanov", je me dis qu'est ce qui peut être pire que de ressembler à Ribery
Ouai mais après les frères Bogdanov, ils ont fait une sorte de chirurgie c'est sûr et certain, même si ils disent non on n'a pas fait ça
Alors que... Ribery, c'est bien naturel.
Ah jsais pas parce qu'il a quand-même des beaux yeux Ribery regarde
Sa mère a volée toutes les étoiles du ciel et lui a mis dans les yeux pour avoir des yeux pareils
J'aime, j'adore la faire celle-là, je l'as fais à toutes les vidéos.
Franchement ressembler aux frères Bogdanov mec
AH! 54% préfèrent ressembler à Ribery
Par contre vous avez pas le même métier, c'est à dire que vous gagnez pas des millions en étant footballeurs hein
Juste vous avez sa gueule, votre méiter est le même hein
Bon, "Boire l'eau des wc", "Inspirer dans un pot d'échappement"
Euh franchement inspirer dans un pot d'échappement mec.
*bruit de ventre*
Mon ventre approuve
Quoiii?
Mais là je comprends pas, boire l'eau des wc mec ?!
L'eau des...Des WC ! Mais pas quand ta mis ton canard wc à... Nan,nan,nan, l'eau, la vraie eau des wc mec !
Mec, alors pot d'échappement tu vas juste faire *inspire* et c'est bon, on en parle plus c'est fini, ça dure 1 seconde.
Nan mais là je m'en remets pas,chui...jsuis presque déçu par mon pays, je vais presque aller vivre en Bretagne.
*cri*
"Squeezie" ou "Cyprien"
Norman!
Bah Cyprien, bah voilà comme 58% des gens on dit
Je...il, il est pas si ouf ce site en vrai
"Constipation" ou "Diarrhée"
Ahhh le grand dilemme hein
Je...jcrois que j'ai jamais été constipé de ma life, jsais pas ce que ça fait, je dirais constipation parce que tu mets un...une sorte de
Bon ba voilà ! Tu mets un suppo dégueulasse et ça passe quoi tu vois
Alors que diarrhée mec, tu manges du riz et ça passe quand-même pas et tu remanges du riz et ça passe quand-même pas
Et 57% des gens bien-sûr pensent que la constipation est mieux.
Je me sens bien quand je suis dans la majorité, c'est un phénomène social qui touche tout le monde euh tu as envie d'être dans la majorité tout le temps.
Voilà, même si la majorité est débile, t'es dans la majorité donc tu te dis qu'elle est pas débile et tu te sens bien.
Jfais un cours de sociaux, ça vous dit?
"Vivre sans musique" ou "Vivre sans téléphone"
Sans téléphone
Mais mec, mais de tellement loin, des fois je m'en bats tellement les couilles alors que la musique mon gars c'est tellement la vie!
D'ailleurs petite anecdote, mon secret avant de tourner une vidéo pour être de bonne humeur, parce que je suis pas toujours de bonne humeur
je me lèves pas toujours du bon pied hein, mon secret c'est d'écouter des musiques que j'affectionne énormément, ça me donne la joie de vivre
jvous jure ! Là par exemple, regardez, j'écoutais une musique juste avant *musique*, j'écoutais ça
Et j'étais comme ça, OUAI! Je suis très heureux! Et j'ai le meilleur métier du monde, allez on tourne! C'est parti.
Hyper gênant.
"Nabilla" ou "Zahia"
Pfffffff
Nan mais mec on en est là quoi
Pfiouuuuu
Zabilla
Chai pas.
Franchement je dirais quand-même Nabilla voilà.
Je sais même pas pourquoi mais, bon voilà je.. en plus jsuis pas la majorité
"Être immortel sur Terre" ou "Vivre 20 ans sur une planète extraterrestre pacifiste"
J'aime bien le pacifiste, pour t'orienter un peu dans ton choix quand-même au cas où tu te dises
Ouai enfin être extraterrestre si c'est pour être esclave et mourir parce que les mecs me tue gratuitement euh
Et ba non ils sont pacifiste, tu fermes ta gueule
Moi j'ai toujours pensé qu'être immortel, ça doit être terrible parce que si t'es seul à être immortel tu vois tous tes proches mourir
les uns après les autres, tu vis plus en fait après ça, même si physiquement t'es immortel, je pense que psychologiquement t'es totalement anéanti
Donc mieux vaux 20 ans sur une planète extraterrestre  pacifiste, voilà
Et mais ça mec je comprends pas, les gens qui veulent être immortel, c'est...c'est bizarre mec comme délire
Ta mère, ton père, ta meuf, ton frère, ta sœur vont mourir
Eux ils seront pas immortel, ils vont mourir, tu vas les voir mourir
Tu feras quoi après, tu seras là "ouai mais moi je suis..." chai pas.
Dans le fond ce que je dis c'est hyper beau mais comme je le dis c'est hyper de la merde
"Fabriquer des maquettes pour C'est pas sorcier"
Mec, on est sur un métier exceptionnel là
Là, là je sais très bien ce que tu penses, tu regrettes que ta conseillère d'orientation t'es pas dit pourquoi tu ferais pas euh
des maquettes pour c'est pas sorcier Lucas plus tard quand tu seras grand
Ou alors "Avoir comme prénom Fred et Jamy"
Mais mec, je veux faire les maquettes mon gars, mais direct! Mec c'est un honneur que Jamy utilise tes maquettes.
Le "Blanc" ou le "Noir"
Ok, le piège c'est d'avoir mis le noir derrière le blanc et le blanc derrière le noir
Nan c'est pas le début d'une blague raciste hein
Le blanc, moi j'aime bien le blanc, ah bah les gens préfèrent le noir, d'accord.
"Perdre 500€" ou "Voler à un sans-abri"
Nan mais mec, perdre 500€, nan mais attend faut arrêter les conneries là
Ah 30% des gens n'ont pas du tout de race, mais alors pas du tout !
Les mecs OSEF à 1000%
Bande de petits enculés
Un "Rasta blanc" ou un "Punk à chien"
Une gifle pour les deux
Un rasta blanc, nan en vrai un rasta blanc moi j'aime bien, ça mfais marrer, c'est drôle quoi
Le mec est né dans le mauvais pays quoi, il aurait vraiment aimé être né en Jamaïque, il est deg de ouf
Et du coup il fait tout comme le gens de Jamaïque sauf qu'il est blanc
Ce qui retire 80% du style, finalement
Un "Ongle incarné"
Un "Oncle incarcéré"
*rire*
Bah l'ongle incarné tu le soignes on en parle plus, t'as pas envie de voir ton oncle incarcéré
Ah d'accord ! Ah 67% des gens sont des gros bâtards, ils ont volés le SDF après passer voir l'oncle incarcéré en prison
Bande d'égoïstes va, un ongle incarné on va te le traiter, c'est fini on en parle plus 2 semaines hop!
Un oncle incarcéré mon pote il fait de la prison c'est chaud
"Manquer de PQ" "Manquer de dentifrice"
Ba mec manquer de dentifrice
Ok.
*blanc*
J'ai raté ma vie là
Manquer de PQ mon pote, tu peux pas t'essuyer, t'es baisé
Tu dois attendre le lendemain avant de pouvoir te...ouai enfin, fin du débat.
Et bien les amis c'est déjà la fin de cette vidéo sur choixdemerde.fr
N'hésitez pas à aimer la vidéo si ça vous a plu, et aller répondre aux questions pour savoir si vous fait partie de la majorité ou de la minorité hein
Vous allez peut-être vous sentir très très mal si vous choisissez pas comme tout le monde, mais ça fait de vous quelqu'un d'unique et d'original.
*bruit de pipe*
Allez, à très bientôt dans une prochaine vidéo, merci d'avoir regardé !
*klaxon*
*outro*